[Música]
[Aplausos]
de ouvir do tempo houve nunca houve
a gente nunca vou fazer faculdade quando
eu tinha 15 anos
o meu sonho é ser o futebol
achava bonito né aqueles meninos com a
parte de baixo do braço andando do
ônibus entre os bancos
achava lindo eu queria ser um office boy
o destino dessa história e eu direi
professor mesmo muito muito mesmo
fui down legal dial-up ao terminal a
história de pai para dar uma prova da
prova assim a história do brasil
coloquei na prova assim o que fez o kaká
me respondeu fez o que pude
o que ele não pode é não fez a pergunta
ficou faltando na minha cabeça era meia
noite
pelo amor de deus o que é isso pergunta
instigava ea cabeça e com semanas
chegando o meu cérebro para pensar em
ser mãe podem fazer é o que o ser humano
pode fazer o que o professor pode fazer
foi aí que eu inventei a minha fantasia
é vencer vou aproveitar essa pergunta e
vou chegar a minha própria pedagogia
a tecnologia do uol o cachorro
pensei comigo que daqui pra frente eu
tenho que falar
do que o ser humano não pode para fazer
3 a 1
primeiro ao autobiografia
autoconhecimento
o primeiro diz respeito a como você se
apresenta ao mundo quem é você venceu em
quem ninguém é capaz de definir uma
pessoa
ninguém é capaz de dizer que é uma
pessoa por exemplo eu sou pt 90 e pelo
melhor parece planos com pijamas né peru
bateu na minha cidade o código
internacional de doença severa bb1
certeza de pólio senhora bem feitinho
ler de novo em termos é fácil me dá a
chave no cemitério tem enterrado em
serve pra nada
aliás médico falou isso pra mim falou
que eu não ia andar falou pra minha mãe
não deixe que nenhum discurso autorizado
defina um médico no df
o dia o advogado do df enquanto o pólo
nos defende
não deixe ninguém conte a sua história
para os outros tem o zé diga de onde
você vê quem são seus pais
quais são seus sonhos
não deixem que ninguém roube a sua
capacidade de contar a sua própria que
história
o segundo álbum é a auto de ímã o que é
a autoestima do nosso meio
ninguém precisa ser bonito e bom eu pra
ter alto em cima dessa beleza assassina
esse jeito agressivo de ser olhar
penetrante
o casal autoestima não é de alto é a
visão de dentro altíssimo tem a ver com
que eu me vejo cordel auto estima o que
gosto de mim o que gosta de dentro de
mim eu construir a minha história eu
contei a história e essa história tem
que coincidir com a minha autoestima eu
e vc como um guerreiro eu não vejo como
herói
eu gosto dessa imagem que eu construir
dentro de mim mesmo que sou francisco
meio ambiental em si é o herói é preciso
um pouco de criatividade para até o
destino que é preciso você competir com
os estereótipos com os padrões
autoestima até onde desde então tem a
ver com o patrão está na televisão no
cinema o que a sociedade julga com o
padrão oficial de beleza de tamanho de
inteligência é o trabalho de
criatividade do sujeito está sujeito a
espécie de criação própria
e o terceiro é o da autonomia
inteligente em estão encantando 11 minas
lá empatia muito esperta pessoa se numa
dessas mil de um serviço pra mim baixou
caem partida chegando em ipatinga já que
ele trabalhou de operário e todo dia que
vem alguns trabalho ele me levava para o
meio ponto inteiro da água marinha perto
do colégio eu ia lá público de queijo
com ele
o queijo muito saboroso salientando que
caiu caiu 2 - comédia rasgada no sangue
começou a chorar e eu comecei a gritar
abea mil vai ensino quer autonomia
meu pai me deu o maior gesto de amor
quem pai poderia dar um fio ele falou e
se toma um novo que eu nem tenho tempo
nos 56 levantar levanta olha pra baixo
que tem vai atuar mas levanta e anda o
que quero dizer pra mim eu acredito em
você você tem capacidade pra ser movido
por você mesmo já não se deixa abater
a vida vai te apresentar mais buracos
mas nunca esqueci dessa voz de comando
levanta e anda meu pai me ensinou a ter
ao todo essa minha pedagogia qual a
metodologia do cachorro
infelizmente eu não pude aplicar essa
tecnologia com meu aluno que no final
desse semestre
ele teve um acidente automobilístico em
um shopping do vale
essa pergunta que gerou essa pedagogia e
fez pensar que é preciso dali pra frente
mudar minha forma de dar aula a minha
forma de dar agora considera um sujeito
a minha forma vital agora tem conteúdo
mas também tem um trabalho de formação
desde o sujeito a minha forma de dar
aula agora não pode presidir da escuta
do sujeito
todo semestre antes de começar
eu escuto cada uma história de cada um
eu passo o que cada história esteja
presente na sala de aula além dos portos
e das aulas das escolas daquelas pessoas
e hoje meus alunos todos vetados da
platéia quando vejo meus alunos bem
sucedidos nas empresas quando os meus
alunos bem sucedidos nos ambientes
culturais
toda vez meus alunos bem sucedidos na
televisão eu lembro sempre dá aquela
pergunta o que pode fazer com um ser
humano
e agora eu fiz pra vocês eu podia trazer
essa mensagem porque essa mensagem por
relacionar e mudou pra mim o papel do
professor que eu disse e que eu ainda
quero ser o verso da minha vida
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]